ja willkommen zur zweiten Vorlesung über
die Philosophie der virtuellen Realität
ich gebe kurz einen Einblick in das was
uns erwartet und so heutiges Programm
heute werden wir erst noch mal ein
bisschen wiederholen die
Begriffsgeschichte und dann aber auf
gegenwärtige Positionen
eingehen die versuchen virtuelle
Realität zu bestimmen und zwar nicht nur
ebistimologisch sondern auch ontologisch
und ethisch das macht zum Beispiel David
charmers macht es dann möchte ich einige
Begriffserklärungen ihnen noch bieten
Virtualität Realität Simulation
Illusion Fiktion das ist alles nicht so
klar und dann kommen wir zum
eigentlichen Thema der heutigen
Vorlesung nämlich der Ontologie der
virtuellen Realität
und abschließend möchte ich versuchen
das habe ich ja gestern schon kurz
angekündigt eine verbindliche Definition
des Begriffs virtuelle Realität ihn zu
geben das hat meines Wissens bisher noch
niemand versucht Gegenteil viele
PhilosophInnen und Philosophen sagen es
ist gar nicht möglich virtuelle Realität
zu definieren das sollen wir auch gar
nicht tun weil uns dann diese schöne
Bandbreite dieses Begriffs verloren geht
das Problem ist natürlich wenn wir den
Begriff nicht definieren wollen oder
sagen wir können nicht definieren dann
öffnet er Tor und Tür für dasjenige was
Jürgen Mittelstraße kritisiert hat
nämlich für bloße Note Philosophie und
haltlose Spekulation das heißt wir sind
als Philosophin und Philosophen
aufgefordert unseren eine Definition
dieses Begriffs zu begeben auch wenn die
vielleicht noch nicht definitiv ist das
wollen wir dann sehen ob sie mit meinem
Vorschlag einverstanden sind
der ist aus einem Aufsatz entnommen der
jetzt demnächst erscheint also die
Definition wurden schon mal geprüft und
für gut befunden aber ich möchte hier
nichts verletzt gültig ausgeben was
nicht durch ihr kritisches
Beurteilungsvermögen hindurchgegangen
ist betrifft natürlich jetzt auch die
ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer auf Youtube auf
die lukasten so wir haben ein paar
Leitfragen
der ganzen Vorlesung gestern haben wir
uns hier mit der Epistemologie befasst
oder auch der Begriffsgeschichte es gibt
einen auch noch ein
begriffsgeschichtliche Dimension heute
steht die Ontologie im Zentrum also die
Frage welche
Form der Existenz besitzt virtuelle
Realität oder virtuelle Realität hin
manche sprechen ja nur von der
virtuellen Realität ich glaube muss
genauer von virtuellen Realitäten sogar
auch von virtuellen
Gegenständen sprechen und die verhalten
sich virtuelle Gegenstände Objekte zum
Beispiel zu körperlichen Dingen
wie existieren diese virtuellen Dinge
wenn es sie gibt in Raum Zeit das sehen
wir die erste Frage existiert etwas und
falls ja wie existiert es oder
existierte zu behaupten in Raum und Zeit
sie hatten gesehen wir haben auch das
platonische höhengleichnis und vor allem
die platonische Linien Gleichnis
diskutiert und wir haben uns gefragt wo
im platonischen Linie Gleichnis ist
bitteschön die virtuelle Realität
anzusiedeln die allermeisten sagen in
der Höhle ganz unten da wo
Schattenbilder sind das ist natürlich
ein Verständnis von virtuelle Realität
was der Ontologie nicht ganz gerecht
wird weil es virtuelle Realität nur
epistemisch versteht und zwar da nur im
Sinne von Simulationen Illusion wenn wir
so Virtualität verstehen als im
schwachen Sinne nur exemisch dann müssen
wir sie tatsächlich in die Höhle
verbannen wir haben auch gesehen bei
ready Player one gibt es auch diese
Höhle diese Höhle von Schrottautos die
sich der Protagonist gleich zu Beginn
zurückzieht um in seiner Scheinwelt in
der virtuellen Realität der Oasis sich
zu vergnügen oder zumindest aufzuhalten
ich glaube wir müssen davon loskommen
von diesem Verständnis von
steinhaftigkeit von
Dunkelheit von Täuschung sondern wir
müssen indem wir den Begriff der
virtuellen Realität definieren
uns aus der Höhle heraus begeben und den
Weg hinaufsteigen ans Licht und das
können wir heute tun den wir einen
stabilen unterologischen Begriff
virtuelle Realität entwickeln und am
Ende auch möglichst hinreichend und
notwendig definieren was virtuelle
Realität ist und es ist auch die Aufgabe
der Philosophie Begriffsklärung zu
machen und sich nicht in Wahrheiten zu
ergehen
deswegen ist aber auch die Frage nach
Raumzeit sehr wichtig wir haben das
gesehen im platonischen Linien Gleichnis
am zahlen und Ideen existieren nicht in
Raum und Zeit zumindest so nicht wie es
Gegenstände tun ja wo existiert in die
Zahl 5 wenn wir sie realistisch
verstehen realistischen dem Sinne dass
sie existiert wo existieren
mathematische Gegenstände offenbar nicht
irgendwie auf einem Tisch so dass wir
ihn an die Zahl fünf anfassen können wie
ein Apfel
sondern irgendwie eine andere wäre und
auch die räumliche Verfasstheit die
zeitliche Verfasstheit ist eben
problematisch wie lange existiert die
Zahl fünf schon existiert sie so lange
schon wie es Menschen gibt existiert sie
seitdem seitdem sie das erste Mal
konzipiert wurde ich weiß nicht wo
vielleicht im alten China keine Ahnung
hat irgendwie jemand mal gesagt das ist
fünf und seitdem gibt es die gibt es die
fünf nicht mehr wenn es keine Menschen
mehr gibt die zählen können oder keine
Wesen mehr gibt die Zellen können das
wäre jetzt eine schwache Auffassung die
ihr stärkere undologische Auffassung
sagt die Zahl fünf existiert unabhängig
davon ob wir auf sie Bezug nehmen ob wir
sie verstehen sie existiert auch dann
wenn es keine Menschen mehr gibt
vielleicht sogar auch prinzipiell wenn
es keine vernünftigen Wesen mehr gibt
das ist jetzt dann aber eine stärkere
these wir wollen ja auch keine
Philosophie der Mathematik machen
bei der virtuellen Realität ist zum
Glück ein bisschen einfacher weil wir
hier das Beispiel des Geldes haben
müssen ja gar nicht so
abstrakt über Zahlen reden sondern wir
können ganz konkret lebensweltlich über
Banknoten reden die ja wie wir gesehen
haben ein gutes Beispiel für virtuelle
Realität abgeben und da wird es ziemlich
klar den Wert hat diese Banknote
natürlich nur so lange wie es diese
Umstände gibt die diesen Wert
konstituieren ich habe schon gesagt
konstituieren das ist natürlich ein
ontologischer Begriff Konstitution und
den werden wir heute genau uns anschauen
also virtuelle Realität existiert immer
stärker gebunden an
vernünftige Subjekte die eben zum
Beispiel im Falle des Geldes dazu
beitragen bei anderen Hinsichten wenn es
jetzt um digitale Objekte gibt geht wird
es ein bisschen schwieriger
wie lange existieren die nachher die
sind auf jeden Fall abhängig von einer
Basis einer technischen Basis die Sie
ebenfalls konstituieren was da sonst
noch für Faktoren eingeht muss man sich
noch genau überlegen jedenfalls Zahlen
werden nicht konstruiert durch eine
vorhergehende Realität auch nicht Ideen
nach Platten bei der virtuellen Realität
ist es anders die ist viel abhängiger
das heißt aber nicht dass sie nicht doch
irgendwie auch ein eigenes autologischen
Status hat
dann wird man morgens mit der Ethik
befassen und deswegen ist die Ethik auch
der Ontologie nachgeordnet weil wir
natürlich uns erst überlegen müssen was
ist denn eigentlich virtuelle Realität
wie existieren sie und erst dann können
wir fragen nachdem virtuellen Handlungen
und nach der normativen Bedeutung von
virtuellen Phänomen wenn wir sie unter
logisch bestimmt haben ist natürlich
ganz klar das gilt natürlich auch für
alle anderen Dinge man muss eigentlich
erst die Ontologie des Handelns
betrachten bevor man genauer fragen kann
was eigentlich moralisch guten moralisch
schlecht ist wir beziehen das jetzt auch
das virtuelle und wir haben jetzt zwei
Anwendungsfälle wir haben einmal das
Metaversum das muss jetzt nicht das von
Metall sein aber ein virtuelle
Handlungsraum und wir müssen uns
natürlich auch im Sinne der
wirtschaftsmetik oder der
Sozialphilosophie kritisch fragen welche
ökonomischen Interessen stehen dahinter
die Frage ist wichtig aber noch
wichtiger ist die Frage was eigentlich
eine virtuelle Handlung ist und wie sich
Virtu Behandlungen von physischen
Handlungen unterscheiden und ob das für
die ethische Bewertung dieser Handlung
ein Unterschied macht ob ich im Mittel
wäre zum etwas Unmoralisches tue oder in
der physischen Welt das ist die
entscheidende Frage ändert sich die
Normativität dann wenn wir ins virtuelle
übergehen oder ist ja das virtuellen nur
ein Spielerei ein Wilder Westen ich habe
mal von dem virtuellen Wilden Westen
gesprochen und diese Alliteration
geltende überhaupt keine moralischen
Gesetze dann gehen wir auch die Ästhetik
über in der übernächsten Sitzung und
wollen uns ein bisschen mit virtueller
Kunst befassen und zwar vor allem am
Status von Computerspielen und von
nft-able Token das sind immer mehr im
Kommen und die haben auch teilweise sehr
hohe Werte das muss man sich fragen
inwiefern können nfts also digitale
ästhetische Objekte überhaupt ästhetisch
sein wenn sie leider gar nicht auf die
typische Weise ästhetisch erscheinen sie
müssen immer bedenken Ästhetik heißt ja
Wahrnehmung auch vom ursprünglichen
Wortsinn heißt das heißt ja was
wahrnehmen und
ein empirischen wahrnehmenden Bezug
herzustellen und wie können wir jetzt
ein ästhetischen Bezug herstellen zu
digitalen Objekten brauchen wir jetzt
anders gefragt eine neue Ästhetik müssen
wir dem Sinn des ästhetischen das
wahrnehmenden und auch wertschätzenden
in dem wahrnehmen eine neue Bedeutung
verleihen wenn es um virtuelle
Gegenstände geht das ist eine spannende
Frage mich interessiert natürlich vor
allem das Computerspiel wir haben das
schon gesehen bei ready Player one
da verschwommen die
virtuelle Realität auch mit online
Computerspielen und wir haben gesehen es
gab eine Welle durch die man surfen
konnte es gab an Minecraft eine
Minecraft Welt da spielen natürlich auch
immer ästhetische Faktoren eine Rolle
und zum Schluss schauen wir uns die
antriebologie an inwiefern können wir
auch virtuell existieren hier ist
natürlich die Thematik des Avatars sehr
wichtig die Rollenübernahme wie verhält
sich ein Avatar zu uns gibt es sowas wie
persönliche Identität auch in virtuellen
das hängt natürlich auch wieder mit der
Ethik zusammen und die Frage nach
Transhumanismus können oder sollen oder
dürfen wir unsere
Identität einfach virtualisieren und
etwa in die Cloud hochladen das wird
häufig von transsoministinnen und
transomalisten vertreten das ist ein
realistischer und wünschenswertes Ziel
sein wir müssen uns fragen ob das
überhaupt eine Form von virtuelle
Existenz ist wie man überhaupt
virtuell existieren kann ja da haben uns
einiges vorgenommen alles aufgezeichnet
und kann dann auch Anschluss nachgesehen
und gerne diskutiert werden zur Methode
der Vorlesung sage ich auch noch mal ein
bisschen was
wir wollen uns also die Frage stellen
was ist Virtualität das haben wir
gestern haben wir uns diese Frage
gestellt was ist Virtualität das ist die
modale Frage weil sich Virtualität
natürlich auch zu Wirklichkeit und
Möglichkeit verhält dann haben wir uns
die
ontologische Frage vorgenommen die wird
heute behandelt Gegensatz zu
illusionssimulation Fiktion also handeln
wir da halten wir uns dann nur in der
Höhle auf oder steigen wir vielleicht
sogar aus der platonischen Höhle heraus
und dann wollen wir synthetisch heute am
Ende den Begriff den geklärten Begriff
der Virtualität mit dem geklärten
Begriff der Realität in ein Verhältnis
setzen das ist dann die
modalontologische Frage ja das
platonische höhengleichnis habe ich ihn
schon mal gezeigt so sieht es bei David
aus und so sieht es in einer ihr
klassischen Ausformung aus wir sind die
Schattenbilder und die Schattenbilder
werden hier jetzt einfach eingegeben
durch virtuelle Realität
hier ist noch mal das Linien Gleichnis
wo Sie die verschiedenen Abteilungen
sehen und jetzt kann man sich wirklich
fragen wo sollte jetzt hier virtuelle
Realität eingeordnet werden hier unten
bei den Abbildern oder eher beim
sinnlich wahrnehmbaren wird schon der
Realität ist jetzt nicht ja so ein
Reihen sinnlich wahrnehmbares das hat
starken epistemischen kognitiven Zugang
es ähnelt als ihr den mathematischen
Gegenständen ist aber zugleich noch
stärker abhängig von den Menschen oder
von einer konstitutionellen Basis was
bei mathematischen Gegenständen nicht
der Fall ist die werden nicht
konstituiert durch eine Basis die
zugrunde ja existieren ja für sich also
es ist ganz schwierig kann man sagen
entweder wir müssen eine neue
Unterscheidung einführen vielleicht
zwischen mathematischen Gegenständen
ziemlich wahrnehmbaren Dingen hier bei C
oder wir sagen die platonische ottologie
hat keinen Raum für das was wir
virtuelle Realität im unterologischen
Sinne nennen können das müssen wir heute
am Ende versuchen zu klären
ähm also wo ist die virtuelle Realität
einzuordnen wenn wir sie on theologisch
realistisch verstehen und nicht wenn wir
sie Anti realistisch verstehen dann ist
die Antwort klar hier unten bei den
Abbildern und hier mache ich eine ganz
kurze Pause dass wir kurz diskutieren
können
ja wir haben gesehen eine Debatte des
Linien Gleichnisses dass es viele
Probleme hat die ganze sozialontologie
ein Staaten Währungen Geld hat hier kein
Platz weil es eben abhängig ist von
menschlicher Subjektivität die Platon
hier gerade aushalten möchte menschliche
Subjektivität hat nur hier im vermuten
oder für Wahrheiten ein Grund
Subjektivität wird für ihn häufig als
was relatives bestanden und virtuelle
Realität hat zumindest Anteile von
Sozial- und Ökologie aber sie geht nicht
darin auf virtuelle Realität hat auch
ein ganz starken medialen Charakter und
technologischen Charakter ich würde
sogar sagen virtuelle Realität verstehen
wir nur in der Einheit von sozialen und
Techno Philosophie oder Medien
Philosophie die zwei Seiten also das
platonische den gleichen platonische
Anthologie suggeriert dass virtuelle
Realität
sind ja Simulation nur hier unten im
Bereich der Abbilder zu verorten sei ich
glaube wir dürfen das so nicht sehen wir
müssen versuchen uns hinauf zu arbeiten
aus der Höhle heraus durch ein adäquates
Verständnis von virtueller Realität und
wir setzen jetzt die Debatte fort indem
ich noch mal ganz kurz zu Bekräftigung
meiner These dass es nicht in der Höhle
zu Verordnung ist natürlich Realität
eher auf die Begriffsgeschichte eingehen
wir haben gesehen es gibt Modalitäten
Wirklichkeiten Möglichkeiten
Notwendigkeit
en müssen wirklich sein aber sie haben
auch ein Anteil von Wirklichkeit und
diese Möglichkeit Aspekt der wird sich
genau noch zeigen in
implikationsverhältnisse die dann bei
Thomas von der Queen deutlicher zu Tage
treten ich kann wie immer verweisen auf
das historische Wörterbuch der
Philosophie das ist die zuverlässigste
Quelle momentan gibt natürlich auch
digitale Weise virtueller Form
auch sehr nützlich in physische Form
haben sie da zwei Meter breite fast wie
ein bruchhaus gehen Sie mal in die
Philosophie Bibliothek das ist Geschoss
glaube ich da steht das Ganze gibt zum
Glück auf digitale Weise
gibt es auch online es gibt es auf CD es
gibt aber auch online die verschiedenen
medialer Form kann man sich viele Fragen
es ist eine virtuelle ein virtuelles
Wörterbuch dann was macht das virtuell
das ist ein spannende Frage das sind die
Fragen nach der Definition nach
notwendigen hinreichend Kriterien dafür
dass etwas eine virtuelle Realität ist
und darauf kommen wir auch heute am Ende
zu sprechen also die antike Philosophie
natürlich auch Platon das platonische
Gleichnis hat noch keinen Begriff von
virtuell aber es lohnt sich immer den
Begriff den lateinischen das Wort sich
anzuschauen Virus Wirkkraft versteckte
würde drin ist der Mann aber natürlich
können auch Frauen kräftig sein manchmal
sogar viel kräftiger als Männer alles
ist nicht bezogen hier auf das
biologische schlecht
der Kraft nach und das scheint mir doch
wirklich das Wesen virtuelle Realität
auszumachen der Kraft nach wenn Sie
virtuelle Realität nur in die Höhle
verbannen dann ist da nichts an Kraft da
ist nur Schwäche welche und schreien und
ethargie und ich weiß nicht was man
alles dem attribuieren kann aber
jedenfalls nicht krass der kraftas deckt
der muss außerhalb der Höhle zu finden
wer kräftig ist bleibt nicht in der
Höhle ganz klar den Trends nach außen
ans Licht genauso trinkt es virtual
Realität sich zu explizieren aus der
Kraft heraus das Verhältnis von Ursache
und Wirkung ist auch ganz wichtig nicht
nur förmlich der Kraft nach also Kraft
nach heißt auch ein bisschen der
Möglichkeiten also Kraft und Möglichkeit
hängen miteinander zusammen die potentia
ist ganz wichtig die Dynamis bei
Aristoteles
das Vermögen Aristoteles aber
Aristoteles kennt nicht den Begriff des
virtuellen und der Begriff der dynamisch
häufig werden wir sehen in Übersetzungen
von virtualis oder virtualika wenn es
Adverb ist dass das dann mit dynamisch
übersetzt wird im deutschen bei kalt
werden wir das gleich sehen das heißt
die Möglichkeit spielt eine große Rolle
aber auch eben die Kraft ein Dynamo
kennen sie oder dynamisch immer früher
gesagt vom Fahrer das ist eine Kraft
enthalten jetzt kommen wir ins
Mittelalter und was von der Queen und
wir lesen in dem historischen Wörterbuch
sie können auch das alles mal genauer
noch nachforschen das werde ich auch
noch dann in meinem Buch tun die
gesammelt so gesamte sumatheologie ist
und lautet das Hauptwerk von
Professionalität viele Bände viel Latein
mal auch virtual ist oder virtualiter
oder ritualität hast oder suchen das
mache ich auch demnächst verlasse ich
mich auf das zuverlässige historische
Wörterbuch und gibt es wieder
da wird gesagt Thomas unterscheidet das
virtuelle essentiellen Material und
aktualis
also das essentiell ist das Wesentliche
vielleicht auch das eigentliche das
explizite des ganz klar zu Tage
tretenden des Materialen das
greifbaren das hängt natürlich auch
wieder mit explizit und dem aktuell das
muss man sich noch mal ein bisschen
genauer anschauen was das aktuelle ist
wir kommen ganz verschiedene
Unterscheidung
spielaktual ist natürlich wirklich
vorliegend ich fasse das auch wieder
eher im Sinne des essentiell und
Materialien also diese Konkretion geht
der Virtualität ist mal ab
obwohl Virtualität nichts essentielles
ist nichts Materiales ist nichts
Greifbares ist ist es dennoch effektiv
es ist entscheiden obwohl es nicht
essentielle materielles hat es eine
Kraft
es kann aktuell werden es muss wirklich
werden aber eben nicht auf diese
unmittelbare Art eine Wirkung B ist man
weiter kann virtuell der Wirkursache a
enthalten sein schon angelegt ist
dynamist da liegt natürlich der Begriff
der Möglichkeiten nahe der Möglichkeit
nach das ist natürlich viel zu
kompliziert um das jetzt hier im Detail
alles auszuarbeiten muss man eine eigene
Studie machen Thomas von der grünen über
Virtualität gibt es meines Wissens noch
gar nicht ja es gibt Untersuchung zu
Leibniz begriff er Virtualität was von
der Queen ist mir keine größere Studie
zumindest bekannt die Wirkung B ist
effektiv beziehungsweise virtuell in der
Ursache enthalten
ja also es ist effektiv es ist wirklich
mächtig drin sind halten aber eben
enthalten und noch nicht
explizit sichtbar und auch nicht
vielleicht Material verwirklicht
dementsprechend sagt auch die virtuelle
Enzyklopädie Wikipedia die man auch ab
und zu befragen darf die natürlich
anderen
objektivitätsstandards unterlegt als ein
Brockhaus oder das historische
Wörterbuch der Philosophie sagt sehr
treffend deswegen bringe ich das jetzt
mit Bezug auf Thomas von Aquin
erstaunlich treffend Virtualität ist die
Eigenschaft einer Sache nicht in der
Form zu existieren in der sie zu
existieren scheint und in der sie
vielleicht normalerweise existiert aber
in ihrem Wesen und ihre Wirkung einer in
dieser Form existierenden Sache
zugleichen Virtualität bezeichnet als
eine gedacht in die tätigen ihre
Funktionalität oder Wirkung vorhanden
ist
ich muss mal so ein bisschen
spezifizieren einer Sache zugleich zu
gleichen darf jetzt nicht so verstanden
werden dass sie nur simuliert
das kann ich das in sein oder sehen Sie
wieder die
Ambivalenz von virtueller Realität oder
Virtualität
real oder realistisch hier spaltet sich
die ganze Debatte ab diejenigen die
zugleichen im Sinne der
simulationsverstehen verbannen die
Virtualität und die virtuelle Realität
in die platonische Höhle es
entscheideweg diejenigen die es
realistisch
ontologischen szenarial verstehen nicht
nur im systemisch die sind auf dem Weg
aus der Höhle hinaus wir sind auf der
Spur unserer Vorlesungen her ja also
auch hier lässt das Ganze noch
Interpretation zu aber es eben nicht die
Eigentlichkeit also wenn etwas virtuell
existiert existiert ist nicht
eigentlichen Sinn also wie es
ursprünglich ist eine Bibliothek eine
physische Bibliothek kann ich
virtualisieren eine virtuelle Bibliothek
ist nicht die Bibliothek wie wir sie
eigentlich kennen ja sonst sie ist eben
das virtualisiert und hat dadurch eben
verschiedene Möglichkeiten
Leibnitz spricht hier von Virtualität
natürlich und Virtualität als
virtualitäten und es wird übersetzt mit
natürlichen Kräften also mit Kräfte es
sind Kräfte es sind keine bloßen
Schattenbilder die Virtualität er sagt
natürlich nicht virtuelle Realitäten er
sagt virtualitäten sprich er gebraucht
Virtualität als
Subjekt im als
Satzglied im Satzglied als Subjekt und
ich als Prädikat
also Virtualität und Realität wären hier
auf derselben Ebene zu sehen als
Subjekte verwendet sie nicht prädikativ
Virtualität
es sind Kräfte
natürlich haben kräftige Signifikanz das
ist ganz klar
und er spricht noch von Urteilen die
virtuell identisch sind wenn man sie
durch begrifflich Analyse auf einmal
Identitäten zurückbringen kann ich habe
das Beispiel gebracht alle Junggesellen
sind unverheiratet ist ein Junggeselle X
ist unverheiratet ich kann das auf
dieselbe Form zurückbringen auf die form
a gleich a ja das Prädikat unverheiratet
ist im Subjekt Junggeselle enthalten
analytisch aber ich muss erst den
Begriff des jugendgefährten explizieren
als unverheirateter Mann und dann kann
ich sagen unverheiratet man ist
unverheiratet gleich a und verheiratet
und verheiratet aber ich habe noch den
Begriff des Junggesellen oder der
Junggesellin ich weiß gar nicht ob sie
gibt keine Ahnung und
dadurch handelt es sich um eine
virtuelle Angelegenheit weil der Begriff
das Junggesellen das unverheiratete eben
implizit enthält und nicht explizit
als enthalten das kann man sagen ist
dieses enthalten auch im Sinne der Kraft
zu verstehen wir haben gesehen dass eine
Ursache die Wirkung nach Thomas von der
Queen virtuell enthält ist genauso auch
im Sinne der begrifflichen
analytischen Kraft
das Prädikat unverheiratet im Begriff
des Junggesellen enthalten
spannende Frage jedenfalls ist es eine
Entscheidung es ist enthalten es ist es
ist da es ist eine präsent aber nicht
direkt aber von der Wirkkraft und des
semantischen Kraft ist es auf jeden Fall
wirklich zu nennen ja also a = a wäre
explizit hingegen zu sagen Junggeselle
ist unfallrat ist implizit aber eben
auch
virtuell identisch muss es entwickeln
ich muss das virtuelle erst zum
Vorschein bringen was aber der Kraft
nach natürlich begrifflich enthalten ist
ein analytisches Urteil nur nicht
explizit
Immanuel Kant spricht dann in seiner
Dissertation von 70 über die Form und
die Prinzipien der Sinnes und
Geisteswelt
vom virtuellen
was nicht räumlich ist es ist aber die
Gegenwart die materiellen Dinge in der
Körperwelt eine virtuelle nicht
räumliche die deutsche Übersetzung
dieses lateinischen Zitats lautet in der
meiner Ausgabe der Grünen meine Ausgabe
eine dynamisch nicht
also virtual ist wird hier mit dynamisch
übersetzen
kant hat es nur auf Deutsch auf
Lateinisch veröffentlicht er hat es
nicht auf Deutsch wir wissen nicht wie
Kant virtualis
übersetzt Deutsch keine Ahnung und ich
muss dazu sagen in ganz gesamten Werk
kommt virtuell ganz selten vor es ist
vielleicht die einzige Stelle ich habe
ganz gesamte Werke digital durchsucht
und das ist eine ganz wenigen Stellen wo
virtuelle
und dann wird es auch noch im deutschen
mit dynamisch übersetzen ja
also dynamisch zeigt zumindest an dass
es ein Vermögen hat eine Kraft hat
natürlich
ich habe jetzt aber virtuell
als es heißt
die Gegenwart präsential Gegenwart hat
ja auch was mit Realität zu tun das ist
etwas tatsächlich
die vielleicht auch die Existenz
Gegenwart ist nicht dasselbe wie
Existenz ja aber es ist sehr verwandt
mit Existenz
die Existenz ist virtuell aber nicht
räumlich die Präsenz
Präsenz ist virtuell aber nicht
und da haben wir natürlich gleich den
Bezug zu
unseren virtuellen Gegenständen wie
Bitcoin
mit Coins existieren sie existieren sie
sind präsent aber sie sind nicht auf
jeden Fall nicht räumlich präsent so wie
es Flaschen sind oder körperliche Dinge
Bitcoins können sich auf Festplatten
befinden die leider aus Versehen
entsorgt wurden und jetzt irgendwo unter
Tonnen von Öl existieren fast zu
dystopisch wie ready Player one da
müssen sich auch dann so rein bohren um
die virtuelle Realität der Bitcoin
Festplatte zu finden interessante
parallel als existieren auf der
Festplatte aber sie existieren auf der
Festplatte nicht so wie die Flasche in
einem konkreten
genauso kann man sich fragen wie
existieren jetzt
Vereine eine sind juristische Personen
eine existieren wo existiert jetzt
bitteschön der
Angelverein München
1903 ev
weiß nicht ob es ihn gibt im Eisbach
Fischen könnt ja Spaß machen ich weiß
nicht ob es erlaubt ist ja
wo existiert der bitteschön der auf dem
Papier würden sie sagt das ist klar aber
das wiederum ist nicht hinreichen
existiert wird diskutieren gleich drüber
existiert
ganz Komplex durch Gesetze durch
Eintragungen ein Register durch seine
Mitglieder die ihn konstituieren das
sind existiert durch seine Bedingungen
die größtenteils Sozial- und
ökologischer Natur sind und natürlich
existieren Vereine auch in unserer
physischen Welt also zumindest haben sie
damit zu tun der Verein kann ein Fest
ausrichten
und wenn er das Fest hier im Innenhof
ausgeht wird dann stinkt sie ziemlich
wenn sie wieder ihre Fische braten und
dann hat das natürlich auch eine
physische eine Wirkung also wir nehmen
es Wasser hat eine Präsenz aber die
Präsenz des Vereins ist hinter diesem
Fischgeruch natürlich nicht physisch sie
ist virtuell
und so können sich das mit allen
möglichen virtuellen Realitäten
vorstellen müssen überhaupt mal auch am
Ende der Vorlesung uns eine ganze Liste
eine ganze Übersicht von möglichen
virtuellen Realitäten dagegen wertigen
wie sie unsere hier entwickelten
Definition entsprechen als ein ganze
Ontologie eine ganzen Kosmos virtuelle
Realitäten dazu gehören nach jetzigem
Stand mit Coins Währungen
es gehören dazu vielleicht auch
nfts oder mit sichere Wahrscheinlichkeit
nFC ist also digitale Kunstwerke
wir müssen uns fragen was da alles dazu
gehört Nationen
zitieren die auch virtuell sind sind
sozial ontologisch zu verstehen also
diese Frage ist spannend eine virtuelle
aber nicht Träume Existenz
und zum Schluss Friedrich Ludwig guter
Weg der Erde im deutschen internismus
zugeordnet wird in seiner Idee eine
Apothek aus dem Jahr 1799 spricht ja
auch von der Virtualität
in der virtuellen in der Virtualität
begegnen einem Kraft und Gegenkraft also
es ist heiß was mit Kraft verbunden ist
und es ist auf das Leben bezogen und das
Leben kann nicht adäquat nur
mechanistisch oder
chemikalisch chemisch verstanden werden
damit kann man sagen nicht
deterministisch reduktionistisch
verstanden werden sondern nur durch den
Begriff der Virtualität
also kein reduktionistischer Begriff des
Lebens sondern was vielleicht
vitalistische schon fast da muss man
sich immer aufpassen vitalistische
Theorien des Lebens sind entziehen sich
häufig auch der genau das gibt dem genau
Verständnis Virtualität heißt hier Kraft
des Lebens dass die nicht
reduktionistisch ist auch Ursache
wirkungsverhältnis in natur
natürlichen Sinne auf naturkausalität
der andere Form von Kraft von Kausalität
muss man sich fragen was damit gemeint
ist eine geistige
Kausalität viele würden sagen das Leben
kann ich nicht adäquat bestimmen wodurch
Physik oder Chemie der Biologie würden
viele sagen Leben ist mehr
guter wird natürlich die Biologin
Biologen sagen ja gut aber dann bist Du
eben jetzt Philosophie oder Philosoph
dann verlässt du die Naturwissenschaften
aber es gibt gute Gründe ein
Lebensbegriff auch zu konzipieren eben
nicht nur biologisch zu verstehen ist ja
wenn man zum Beispiel von Lebensformen
spricht von Lebensart spricht von
Lebensstil sprich vor etwas was belebend
aktivierend ist dann riecht der
Lebensbegriff sehr kontrovers aber es
gibt Bedeutung von leben wo wir sagen
dieser Begriff ist jetzt sinnvoll
verwendet aber wir können nicht nur
biologisch verstehen ja
Lebensform zum Beispiel Lebensart
das ist was was mit unserem biologischen
Leben zu tun hat aber darauf nicht
zurückzufügen ist ja savoir wie
französische Lebensart
er ist wenn Sie die versuchen biologisch
zu bestimmen dann wird sich jeder
Franzose jede Französin sein als die
spinnst doch ja dabei ist es hängt das
mit dem Leben zusammen das hat also eine
kulturelle Dimension vielleicht
und jetzt spricht er hier von tierischer
Virtualität
da mal tierische Kraft Lebenskraft
vielleicht die sei blinde Subjektivität
also die die Virtualität die kann auch
zu Bewusstsein kommen wie Menschen wenn
ein Strahl der Vernunft sich in der
virtuellen der Virtualität zeigt da ist
der Wille frei also Virtualität und
streben sind natürlich auch jetzt
irgendwie verbunden und Freiheit das
läuft meiner Auffassung von virtuelle
Realität sehr
nicht so wie das gegen das kommt ja sehr
entgegen weil ich ja die These vertreten
hatte dass virtuelle Realität nur dort
vorhanden ist wo wir es schon mit
kulturellen Leistungen zu tun haben
sprich Geld also virtuelle Realität ist
nichts was einfach so vorliegt wie
natürliche Gegenstände sie hat etwas von
Artefakten von künstlichkeiten aber eben
noch mehr als lose Artefakte sie ist
eine Transformation eine
Realisierung eines Zweckes auf anderen
Wegen nämlich indirektem Weg
ja so viel zur Begriffsgeschichte da
Stopp ich noch mal ganz kurz um Fragen
Raum zu geben und dann machen wir weiter